[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo iba en esta escuela y recuerdo que me
gustaba mucho este libro que se llama
world en viviendo en el bosque lo
subraya de manera muy meticulosa con
diferentes colores haciendo anotaciones
y hace poco me dio muchas ganas de
volver a leerlo
no lo encontré obviamente lo había
perdido así que lo volvió a comprar lo
redescubrir lo volvió a leer lo volví a
subrayar casualmente el libro obviamente
estaba debajo de mi cama así que tuve la
gran oportunidad de comparar estos dos
de alguna manera algunas cosas se habían
quedado y otras eran completamente
diferentes me puso a reflexionar que
esto que subrayaba esto aquello que le
ponía atención en mi vida era como un
mapa para conocerme a mí mismo
de alguna manera del mismo libro pero el
federal diferente podría haber a través
de este en la secundaria que consideraba
importante y bello creo que
a través de conectar los puntos de
nuestra narrativa es cómo podemos llegar
a entender el mundo que nos rodea ya
nosotros mismos y qué son las historias
sino el ciclo del crecimiento humano lo
que todos vivimos tendrá estas historias
habrá capítulos donde nos encontremos
totalmente perdidos sin entender porque
realmente estamos viendo eso no parece
ser este capítulo no parece ser parte de
la trama general o al menos de lo que
creíamos que se trataba esta bella
historia la nuestra pero también habrán
capítulos donde todos los puntos se
conecten con simetría donde de alguna
manera hace sentido todo porque sabemos
de dónde viene nuestro personaje sabemos
dónde está parado y sabemos cómo
terminará la historia porque conocemos
este personaje y su propósito dentro de
ésta
he encontrado que en esta era de la
omnipotencia de la información donde
estamos siendo constantemente
bombardeados por anuncios distracciones
facebook redes sociales a mí en lo
personal me dificulta un poco más
conectar estos puntos pone atención
realmente en lo que importa decidir qué
es importante que no que se subraya
dentro de esta historia y hace que me
quede un poquito más de lo necesario en
estos capítulos confusos otro de estos
factores muy grandes que me hacen
atraparme dentro de este ciclo es el
temor
quien vive temeroso nunca será libre y
pues obviamente esto me hace muchísimo
sentido yo quiero ser libre de mis
miedos para poder continuar dentro de
esta historia por ejemplo le tengo
terror a las alturas pero su perfil
siempre es muy real que no es a las
alturas es a caerme
un día caminando por las calles de
cholula me encontré con los voladores de
papantla y se me ocurrió la brillante
idea de acercar uno de ellos y pedirle
que se le podría amarrar mi cámara a su
cabeza para poder tener una foto desde
las alturas de la belle cholula a lo
cual me respondió por qué no mejor yo te
amarró a ti a ese poste de 20 metros y
este tú tomas la foto
a ese poste de 20 metros a marrón es
solamente una cuerda de mkt porque se
mandó una cuerda de mercantilistas es
para un arnés
y después explicó que primero subes y
después ya arriba te amarran
obviamente en este momento me aplasta
van dos fuerzas en mi cabeza por un lado
estaba esa pequeña voz que decía vamos
ser supera tus miedos para vivir libre
de ellos y tener una foto en facebook
como volador de papantla
pero esto era solamente una voz por el
otro lado estaba mi miedo hablándome de
lo bello que sentir el piso bajo tus
pies de lo cómodo que es esto de alguna
manera este miedo me contiene dentro de
mi burbuja de conformidad y la verdad es
ésta yo odio salir de la burbuja no es
algo muy placentero ni que me guste no
me gusta levantarme temprano me gusta
contestarla mi contador me gusta ser
adulto no me gusta admitir que me
equivoqué odio todas estas cosas por eso
no me podría imaginar imaginar vivir
fuera de la burbuja son demasiado
cómodos el autoengaño la procrastinación
la flojera
todas estas bellas fuerzas que aprietan
el botón desnudos 15 veces antes de que
me levante y no es broma tengo como 15
alarmas
tanto así que me voy mi burbuja de
confort se ve así en 15 años
este diseño en 15 años y aunque todas
estas fuerzas son muy bellas
lamentablemente me frenan dentro de mi
ciclo de crecimiento hace poco estaba
comentando esto con mi amiga florencia y
me mandó uno de estos meses que te
mandan sus abuelas por whatsapp por las
mañanas frases inspiracionales que
repite amanezco como con 15 pero este de
verdad si se queda mucho en mi cabeza la
causa principal del fracaso y la
infelicidad es cambiar lo que más
quieres por lo que eres en un momento y
claro me hace muchísimo sentido lo que
yo quiero en el momento es darme la
vuelta a distraerme y decirme que no
tengo que realmente lidiar con esto
ahora pero lo que yo más quiero en
realidad
vivir esta historia y vivir este
conflicto central dentro de éste
de alguna manera todas estas fuerzas que
me empujan a salir de la burbuja del
amor la curiosidad de la valentía
lamentablemente van y vienen sin mi
permiso no es como que las tengo
disponibles en mi bolsillo por lo tanto
cada vez que me encuentro frente al
poste de 20 metros mirando hacia arriba
olvidó por completo todas las veces que
he sido valiente
de alguna manera mi cabeza me pone
trampas para no encontrarse en una
situación incómoda o en este caso
peligrosa
el último poste de 20 metros que me
encontré en mi vida fueron el alcohol y
las drogas de alguna manera se volvieron
un problema de que me estaba matando
física y espiritualmente decidí dejar de
hacerlo que fue una de las cosas más
difíciles que he hecho y sin embargo en
mis primeros meses de abstinencia de
sobriedad me di cuenta de que este
problema derivaba realmente una
necesidad de distracción
necesitaba distraerme de mi realidad
realmente no quería lidiar con este
conflicto central de la historia
entonces utilizaba ya no a las drogas
pero ahora eran los videojuegos las
personas o era este mis redes sociales
sobre todo mi celular todo aquello que
me diera este placer momentáneo
me encontraba otra vez frente al poste
de 20 metros mirando hacia arriba y
olvidando todas las veces que había sido
feliz sobre en esta vida
encontrar en este capítulo confuso donde
solamente subrayaba aquello que me
dieron placer momentáneo solamente del
momento nada de la trama general no
quiero saber nada de la trama final y
entonces esto obviamente creó muchísima
infelicidad y muchísimo conflicto porque
realmente no mental con lo que tenía que
hacer con lo que se trataba de esta
historia
pero en un momento recordé que yo he
estado aquí antes yo había estado en
esta parte del ciclo de hecho use mi
amor por la magia recuerdo para romper
mi miedo a acercarme a las personas y
había funcionado entonces tuve un
poquito de esperanza de que ya había
estado aquí y este ciclo podría
continuar entonces es muy consciente de
que mi problema principal era que me
estaba distrayendo de lo que sentía
decidí quitar todas distracciones
recuerdo que me senté un día cansado de
estar en este ciclo en mi cocina apoyo
mi celular no le habla nada y me senté
en uno de estos bancos altos en mi
cocina y tuve después de cinco minutos
tuvo una epifanía gigantesca y me di
cuenta de algo increíble es
absolutamente aburrido estar nadamas
sentado sin hacer nada
estamos tan acostumbrados a distraernos
todo el tiempo es como algo ya
automático como que quería sacarnos
hablar de izquierdo tenía la bolsa
recuerdo que me prometí sentir lo que
estaba sintiendo en ese momento no
distracciones y en ese instante recuerdo
ver a través de mi cocina este terrario
que tengo lo había regado esta mañana
recuerdo me gustan las plantas me acerco
le quitó la tapa y me llega este olor
llamado petri core que es como el olor a
tierra mojada después de que llueve y
sentí como esta sensación de un profundo
afecto por este recordaba que yo amaba
este olor que amo las plantas que todos
estos recuerdos que se ligan a él petri
corme llegaron en un instante y sabía
que éste era algo digno de subrayarse en
esta historia no sabía por qué pero esto
que sentía era como un salvavidas para
salir de este pequeño capítulo de
depresión y distracción así que decidí
tatuar melo en la espalda
pero si decidí que tenía que sea algo
subrayando en esta historia así que
recuerdo que hice una lista de canciones
que me recordaran este olor la llama
petri core de ahí regresé y recordé mi
profundo amor por la música pero
organicé todas mis listas de música
componiendo los títulos creativos como
con colores de ac y de ahí recordé mi
amor por el cine reorganiza todas mis
listas de películas favoritas por por
orden de preferencia que sigue en
progreso pero de ahí regresé a mi amor
por la fotografía y de repente me
encontré como anhelando todas estas
pasiones otra vez decidí quitar todos
mis seguidores todas las personas que
sigo en instagram realmente no me
aportaban nada mi cuestión fotográfica y
me embarqué en una búsqueda por nuevos
fotógrafos de todo el mundo que los
tengo en el celular simplemente es
buscarlos ahí están y me encontré con
fotógrafos increíbles uno de ellos es
rebbeca garrido que es una chava que
bien monterrey que solamente osea toma
sus fotos desde el celular quedé
anonadado con esto este platicamos un
poco por mensajes y
es me pareció muy impresionante
encontrar gente tan talentosa en el
internet
tan mágico fue esto que un día casual me
encontraba comiendo en la ciudad de
mexico y la mesa de al lado estaba
rebeca
se levantó y me saludó y no podía
creerlo más yo que era este momento
inmediatamente nos pusimos a platicar de
todas estas bellas cosas que armamos
acerca de crear contenido por internet y
como era tan raro que amamos tanto estas
cosas y sin embargo no hacíamos tan
seguido corte a dos semanas después nos
encontramos en un viaje donde hicimos un
proyecto llamado inherente hicimos una
sesión de fotos pero también hicimos un
vídeo arte pero también hicimos una
lista de música escribimos un poema y de
repente me encontraba otra vez en este
capítulo donde sentía que todo era
inevitable donde todo el largo de mi
personaje hacía perfecto sentido y
estaba en esta parte de la historia que
era increíble
de alguna manera siento este es una
frase de un director ruso que me encanta
dice la poesía es una conciencia del
mundo una manera particular de
relacionarse con la realidad esto me
hizo entender muchísimo toda mi pasión
por lo que hago porque de alguna manera
mis vídeos mis fotos mis creaciones son
mi manera de subrayar aquello que
considero importante en la vida son como
un mapa para conocerme a mí mismo y
decidimos regresar a estos a aprender
algo de esta historia y no regresar a
este punto de distracción tan difícil
aprendí que el celular es mi enemigo
número uno así que bajé una aplicación
que me cuenta cuántas veces entro diario
al celular
385 veces entre todos los días a mi
celular a desbloquearlo y lo peor es que
el 90% de estas veces no tengo ni idea
de lo que estoy haciendo
soy como un mono pelando una banana
infinita que realmente nunca llega al
plátano
es absurdo creer que toda esta
información que de estas 385 veces no
afecta de alguna manera mi narrativa
porque esto es diario
hay una frase de gandhi que me gusta
mucho que creo que lo puede ilustrar
cuida tus pensamientos porque se
convertirán en tus palabras cuida tus
palabras porque se convertirán en tus
actos cuida tus actos porque se
convertirán en tus hábitos cuida tus
hábitos porque se convertirán en tu
destino creo que esta frase cobra todo
el nivel en esta era digital cuida a
quien sigas en instagram porque
terminarás siendo como ellos
lamentándose porque no lo eres o
haciendo un viaje de 10 días haciendo lo
que más amas en la vida con ellos
creo que en esta era digital lo que es
nuestro recurso más importante es
nuestra atención a que le imponemos
atención todos los días porque aquello
que le ponemos atención es aquello que
subrayamos dentro de esta bella historia
la nuestra y podemos tomar la edición de
qué es esta historia una comedia
romántica este un misterio a punto de
resolverse o es una aventura a punto de
comenzar todo es dependiendo de aquello
que tú le pongas el valor de la atención
y gracias a eso podrás en cualquier
momento que te encuentres frente a un
poste de 20 metros yo siempre que me
encuentro ahora frente a un poste a 20
metros puedo voltear a ver mi historia
aquello que subrayado y recordar todas
las veces que he sido valiente
gracias
[Aplausos]